I am the resurrection and I am the life
says the Lord
whoever has faith in me shall have life
even though he died George Herbert
Walker Bush was America's last great
soldier statesman a 20th century
founding father an imperfect man he left
us a more perfect union fifty or a
hundred years from now as historians
review the accomplishments and the
context of all who have served as
president I believe it will be said that
no occupant of the Oval Office was more
courageous more principled and more
honorable than George Herbert Walker
Bush
most decent and honorable person I ever
met with my friend George Bush one of
nature's noble men his epitaph perhaps
just a single letter the letter L for
loyalty it coursed through his blend
your decency sincerity and kind soul
will stay with us forever
so through our tears let us know the
blessings of knowing and loving you a
great and noble man the best father are
selling their daughter could have and in
our grief but a smile knowing that dad
is hugging Robin and holding mom's hand
again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]